let me pull this story up here and then
we'll talk about u.s and china
axios reports americans increasingly see
china as an
enemy overall 55
view america as a competitor so you were
right earlier i was wrong you mentioned
it was about 34
viewed it's an enemy among republicans
53 view china as an enemy
and only 20 of democrats but it's about
a third of americans
see china as an enemy perhaps not uh
not enough for any real conflict but at
least in that regard with china now
demonizing the united
states i wonder if this is a step
towards a potential military conflict
i don't know where you guys your views
are right now between that
that scenario happening well
so for a point of context um the
situation
in hong kong uh the chinese communist
party has been very successful
at uh completely annihilating any trace
of democracy
in hong kong once hong kong is taken
care of to the communist party's
satisfaction the next goal
is taiwan and that is something that
will draw in the entire
world the u.s has made obligations
to defend taiwan in the event of any
kind of uh
invasion um and taiwan is a very
strategic location in the region
so sooner or later we are going to see
taiwan become a flashpoint
uh but is biden going to actually
protect taiwan
well i uh i don't know uh
he well he so he was the the first
president to have uh
essentially what the is the taiwanese
ambassador it's not they're not called
an ambassador because of
the one china whatever yeah but he was
the first president to have this
taiwanese representative come to the
inauguration
he has carried on uh freedom of
navigation operations in the south china
sea and in the taiwan strait
uh so he's done all of those things we
just
he hasn't explained what his china
policy is
so in many ways the the by
administration has said
many of the right things but they
haven't
done much yet yeah and it is six weeks
six weeks right
right and even the trump administration
it took it took a while for
that administration's china policy to
kind of crystallize
um for a variety of reasons you know
looking at
the uh us migrant crisis that's
happening right now and
and i'm not assuming you guys know a lot
about it but joe biden is getting a lot
of criticism from the left and the right
it's it's typically being seen as a
dramatic failure by
all by both political parties obviously
there are establishment democrats who
are supportive of joe biden
republican party trump populist types
they're super critical and left
populists are looking at joe biden as
though he's failing miserably in this
regard
because he's not really getting anything
done he's not helping the migrants in a
capacity where they'll be able to come
in here and get health care and get
access well they're kind of coming in
and being released it's not all that
great
some are being deported but then the
trump supporters see it as he's not
doing anything to stop
it i only bring that up because i have
to wonder if that's something that we
really can see and understand as
americans we understand the border
we understand the arguments made around
it is that a sign of joe biden's
leadership on other issues as well which
may
you know reflect on what could happen
with china well i think from things that
have been said and again this is things
that have been said and not done
they talk about uh diplomacy cooperating
with china
china might be a rival or a competitor
but you know we need to cooperate with
them
on climate change cetera et cetera but
the fundamental issue is when you look
at the chinese communist party as a
regime that is committing
genocide and that as we can see in the
case of hong kong
lies about any promise it makes
how can you cooperate how can you be
diplomatic
with this kind of monstrous
authoritarian regime so it blows the
fundamental premise of what he's said
yeah out of the water i think the danger
for the u.s and the biden administration
here is that
they are going to want to differentiate
differentiate themselves so much from
the trump administration
that like they have to be like well we
are going to be diplomats we're going to
talk about diplomacy we're going to talk
about cooperation
this whole line about china being a
rival but we have to still cooperate on
shared
goals is one that's consistently been
said by like every biden
nominee that's gone up in front of like
senate hearings or whatever so
you have to say this is the line from
the biden administration the problem is
that's not what the chinese communist
party means by cooperate
the the word in chinese it just kind of
means like exchange
in any way so it could be just like you
know the cooperation doesn't it doesn't
mean like we're going to both work
together on climate change
it means if you want me to do something
about climate change uh
yeah what are you going to give up like
what are you going to give me
i don't think they're going to do
anything i think i think it's
duplicitousness oh yeah they're going to
say don't worry america we got you
you give us the billion dollars and then
we'll get right on it thanks to the bill
and then what billion dollars well the
promise was in four decades we'll be
carbon neutral
yeah or building more coal-fired power
plants yeah right i mean we've seen
we've seen challenges with cooperating
with the chinese communist party in the
past
if you look at the george w bush
administration
they initially took us a tough stance on
the communist party but after 9 11
they're like well we have to work with
the communist party on fighting the
biggest threat which at the time was
terrorism and so the idea is we're going
to work with china
to fight global terrorism and what did
china do if they didn't
cooperate towards america's goals on
fighting terrorism
they basically used it as an excuse to
go after
their chinese muslims like the uyghurs
right
the obama administration then said oh we
have to cooperate with china on climate
change
and you know what what happened while
china signed you know the
paris agreement but but ultimately
what the china actually do was
build a huge number of coal-fired power
plants releasing massive amounts of
carbon they ramped up their carbon
emissions
while using the excuse of being a
developing company country
but on top of that they also stole
the renewable energy technology from u.s
companies wind
power technology and solar technology
and now if you want to buy
a solar panel in america
you're basically buying one that's made
in china from knocked off
american technology and that's how the
communist party cooperates on climate
change it is also
it's also uh powered by coal right right
so
when they build them you know you're
ragging on china coming down real hard
over the the burning of this carbon and
all that stuff
but they did build that big tv thing
right that showed the sunrise
oh i know that yeah yeah yeah there's
all the smog in the air you got to give
them credit for at least giving people
a glimmer of hope right it can't just be
a dreary post-apocalyptic smog
ping promised he's gonna transform china
into a moderately prosperous society
i i gotta i gotta say i think uh i i
feel like the us has already lost
you know i think we're we're in a
propaganda war an information war and
economic war
and we are i i don't think the physical
confrontation matters as much
if it comes to a point where taiwan
knows the u.s has become too weak to
actually defend it
and their option is allow china to come
in or die
i mean i feel like they might just be
like well we've got no defense anymore
we've got no leverage that's it we're
china now
it's it's hard to say because they know
what what it would mean for taiwan
is they become the next hong kong and
hong kong is looking more and more
a little less like shanghai and a little
more like xinjiang that was a point you
made the other day where it's it's very
what does that mean it means like it's
basically
like when the chinese communist party is
turning hong kong into another chinese
city they're not turning it into like
shanghai or beijing like
one of their cities they're turning into
xinjiang which is basically an open-air
prison
right like there was like all the
crackdowns in hong kong now like they're
basically going to
uh essentially strip out all the
democracy that existed
like no more being able to vote for
people in the legislature
like it's just they're completely
dismantling it and
there's maybe a bill that's going to
come up in front of the legislature that
is now completely controlled by
pro-beijing officials uh that would
allow the hong kong government to stop
people from leaving hong kong wow
like so that then it really does become
like a giant prison and there is no
prominent hong kong
activist that is they're all either in
jail or in exile
at this point and a lot of people we had
interviewed in hong kong just
a year and a half ago are in jail now
wow
yeah so really what happens in taiwan
will determine
whatever happens within x but i mean you
look at you look at these these american
companies that's why i say it
that who was it lebron james who came
out and defended
china and then you had was it steve kerr
i think it was
well we don't talk about black lives
matter well you know or they don't talk
about so we're not going to talk about
what's going on over there and it's like
dude they're the concentration camps
like
it's a it's a big difference you got and
the nba has a training camp in shenzhen
and disney thanks
yeah we talked about all these
industries they make so much more money
there
you go you got to look at who who owns
these big companies and and their access
to wealth
american companies i i shouldn't even
call them american companies necessarily
they're multinational corporations at
this point and the people in charge of
them are like
i'm rich i can do whatever i want and no
one will stop me
why would i care about anybody else i
mean blackrock has this whole web page
about unleashing the potential of
chinese bonds
like yeah what does that mean it means
like invest your money in china
yeah pump up the regime yeah you'll
invest your money in china
you'll get back a good return and you
will sell out everyone else into
serfdom or slave labor if china takes
taiwan
uh china becomes a superpower it's no
longer
the u.s is more powerful it's it would
be a tremendous loss
for this democracy yeah this is what uh
xi jinping was saying about the
you know west is in decline the east is
rising
i mean it's true yeah so that's uh
that's
but at the same time saying that the us
is the biggest threat
to china so um more like
the us is the dominant power around the
world and it's who needs to be displaced
if china has to take over
what about the eu they'll stand up my
understanding is that the goal of the
european union was to compete with china
because they saw you know how quickly it
was rising and they needed some kind of
united force
they're not succeeding at that no
they're not that that's yes
uh and that has to do with uh the the
the
manufacturing and corporate power of
germany in particular uh being very
interested in developing relationships
with china angela merkel has been very
supportive of that
uh and they volkswagen went into china
in like 1978 or 79
like the first western company to go
into china volkswagen has a
bad history well all of these companies
that go into china they
they create a chinese communist division
within the company for the communist
party so if you have
50 or more employees then you're
required by chinese law to have a party
branch within your company and this
applies not just to chinese companies
but also to foreign companies foreign
companies also have to work
with a chinese company yeah so so yeah
they need a partner and until recently
it had to be a majority
uh partner 51 majority uh and so
essentially the foreign company can
operate but
there are certain things that they can
and can't do according to the party
whims and the party is
is in there with every major decision so
yeah like mcdonald's having a party
branch
in china does like it's hard to
understand like what that would really
mean
but when it comes to like volkswagen so
their party branch is going to help
arrange things
like uh cheap labor for example or
nike you know we'll have a party branch
and may and maybe there's
there's certain political things that
nike can't say and there's also possibly
the help that they give for
you know you get very cheap labor from
uh from uighurs who
don't have much choice well this is why
nike was
fighting against a forced labor bill
that would have
potentially gotten them trouble for
using forced labor and xinjiang
not that they were directly using it but
because of the web of how many of like
you know you source something
from this person who sorts something
from this company down the line and then
somewhere along the line
there's uyghur slave labor i mean it was
so easy and cheap so they decided to
just do it
it's not just weaker slave labor there's
a lot of prison like there's just like
a lot of uh you know kind of dissident
prison labor
it's not just the uyghurs it's just that
the weakers are the biggest population
right it's very invisible in a way
they're an ethnic minority so you can
kind of tell who they are
in one region versus just like
well like so the issue with falun gong
was they were just anybody
they're just people who do the qigong
practice and so they blended in they
weren't like in one location so you
couldn't like see
like oh this is the specific
concentration camp where they're putting
them right
so this sounds horrible
yeah we we do not want the chinese
communist party as a superpower leading
the world i don't think we can do
anything i think
i i is it pessimistic to say it's over
what do you guys think
uh i think it is pessimistic uh there
has been
you know we all know the trump
administration was a bit
controversial china was one of the few
bipartisan issues
um i i would imagine the
administration says it's reviewing the
trump administration designation of
what's happening to the uyghurs as
genocide i can't imagine it would be
politically feasible
for biden to come out and say well you
know it maybe it isn't genocide i just
can't imagine
what happened he came out and said well
you know there are cultural differences
in china
what he said was wrong for many reasons
not quite that he he has been clear
about uh
condemning what the treatment of of the
uyghurs
i don't think he'll use the word
genocide personally not yet
because like it's just like how the
canadian parliament recently
voted that it was genocide but trudeau
and his entire cabinet
basically just didn't show up for the
vote yeah because they
were like the government abstains like i
can i can
i can actually understand and respect
why joe biden would not do that
because he needs to go in and be able to
have some kind of relationship
to actually have influence in a certain
capacity however while i can understand
that and same is true for trump when he
would go negotiate like why is he
talking to kim jong-un or whatever like
well
what he's going to do throw a bomb first
it's at a certain point there's a line
we've got to figure out how we stop
these things
i mean the the gulags in in north korea
are nightmarish
and the and the genus the genocide and
the concentration camps in in china are
probably the worst possible thing you
know we could imagine existing
in terms of what a human could do to
another human how do we stop it
if we don't have a president who's
willing to say that's the line the line
is
shouldn't the line for i don't care if
it's trump or biden be literal genocide
he should say it shouldn't trudeau say
it well as you say that's
it prevents them from having any kind of
diplomacy quote unquote yeah but but
the way i see it is when you when you
enter into genocide
yeah is diplomacy really soft diplomacy
i mean you could still have diplomacy to
a certain degree
you could have i'm gonna you know we're
we're sanctioning you
we are making demands you end this now
or else
because this is a red line but we we
have these we have trudeau and binding
who are like well now hold on there you
know
yeah you need to have red lines that
there are consequences for crossing
those red lines and i think
we had all the red lines with syria yeah
well i think with the genus this is why
genocide is such a touchy
issue it's if western democracies and
now the dutch parliament has come out
and also called it a genocide
if they actually start using the word
genocide then it becomes a lot harder
for
not just like leaders of countries to
just act like china's normal country but
also
you know wall street for businesses
because really
the thing that we can do to stop china
is to cut off the money
yeah that's number one they won't do it
yeah you have all these special
interests like i
mention the nba you had blizzard the
hearthstone thing with free hong kong
yeah
well that's free hong kong's long since
passed i suppose
there's there's an opportunity each and
every step of the way for companies to
say
no to china and they don't do it no i
think that's
where it has to be like
when we were talking about how people
now see more and more people see china
as an enemy
or like like some kind of threat like it
has to be people who it has to be so bad
for these companies in the us
to not cut off that source of money in
china or whatever that they are willing
to do it like
if if the if the alternative is they
really like with google and dragonfly
like
it's such a bad thing for them that they
actually have to stop
like that's that's where we have to go
that was uh employee revolt wasn't it
yeah yeah employees at google said no to
the
you know dragonfly the dragonfly was
that yeah and good on them and i wish
employees at nike in the nba would
i mean if if you had you know if you had
a bunch of nba star like
real stars who had said you know uh
we got to condemn what's happening there
then there
there'd be enough public pressure that
there there couldn't be much the nba
would do
lebron james needs to call out genocide
right and you know it's it's fine
like i have no problem with with
basketball players using their
fame to talk about political issues in
the us what's happening in china
uh is so bad that like if you even talk
about it in china you get
arrested uh so you know you can't
criticize your own government inside
china
it's a very different situation but i
think the the overall
looking at um why is the chinese
communist party so powerful and have
they gotten so much power in the last 20
years
it's all because of foreign investment
it's partly just the money directly like
investing in
chinese bonds investing in chinese
companies and that sort of thing
but it's also the foreign companies
coming in giving their technology
allowing chinese companies to learn from
and even steal a lot of this technology
and help compete these industries
and then it's us buying those knockoff
products back here in the u.s
so that whole economic system is the the
fundamental core of that is
foreign companies especially us
companies engaging in that market
so to to the degree that you can cut off
the
the foreign company or american company
interaction
with china that's the degree to which
we're going to be able to rein in
that authoritarian power and we have to
focus there
but it's it's clear that even you know
even the trump administration which
which seemed to really want to do it was
was unable to achieve a whole lot with
that
um well it's going to take a lot a lot
more
google dragonfly situations where people
working here
who have that power as employees the
empower
citizens in his media to say we're not
going to tolerate
our companies working with a genocide
dictatorship
also you know consumers not buying
products made in china
don't go to an nba game yeah like it has
to the other thing that
the us government could do was what the
trump administration started doing like
actually putting chinese companies that
work with chinese military on
entity lists like blacklisting them so
getting them de-listed from the stock
yeah so soon they're going to be a big
bunch of big chinese companies that
can't trade on wall street anymore
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you